- All right, well, thank you
all for attending this session.
I'm gonna have to get used to the fact
that you're all wearing
headphones, and I'm not,
so I'll just trust that you
can hear and are interested.
So we are here to talk
about something, I think,
that has really evolved
tremendously over the last year
is the security implications
specific to how AI
is, you know, fundamentally
shifting what we do in security.
And so this is gonna be
a conversational piece
where my friend Ammar here
and I are going to talk about
things that we're seeing,
some of the best practices that
we have been looking to implement,
or, you know, maybe Adobe has implemented.
But just for a quick introduction,
this is a session where both Fortinet and
Adobe have, you know,
kind of collaborated.
Ammar and I have done this a few times,
you know, not in this
topic, but various topics.
And so I love how he frames things.
But, you know, Ammar, thank
you for being with me.
I always appreciate, you know,
the opportunity to do
these things with you.
Maybe quickly introduce yourself.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Really happy to be here.
re:Invent is one of my favorite
conferences as an AWS Community Builder.
And before we start, I just
wanna understand the room
and see who are, get to
know the audience more.
Just raise your hand who here is
responsible for securing
AI workloads?
- Oh, that's a pretty big number.
- Who here is being asked to
use AI to do something, whether
it's security, operations?
- Okay. All right, so we've
got the right audience.
- One last question,
who here has not used AI
yet,
planning on?
Okay, we have a couple.
I expected maybe five, so two is not
- [Aidan] Yeah.
- too off, so yeah, I'm excited to be here
to talk about the implications.
I think from 2019,
maybe to 2030,
is going to go down in history as a very
big moment in human history, right?
It's similar to discovering electricity or
hospitals,
fire, like so many-
- The internet.
- The internet, absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Those changes are
coming at us very fast.
Like, sometimes my team
deploys something that is AI,
and as a security person, I'm not aware.
Why? Because they wanna
keep up with the market.
They wanna move fast. They
don't have time for checks.
So we all here to kind of
figure it out together,
and without further ado, I'm
just gonna introduce myself.
I'm Ammar.
I am an AWS Community Builder, and I also
like look after DevOps,
the DevOps team at Adobe,
so a little bit of
cloud, web applications,
and AI security.
Without me signing up for
any of the AI security,
I found myself, like many of you guys,
my applications has AI in them,
and now I'm responsible for AI security.
- Yeah, I think that the
scale that Adobe has in AI
is why I like getting your input.
It's like you have literally
hundreds of applications
that are quite mature.
I use these applications.
I'm sure many of this audience uses them.
And so, you know, for my part,
you know, we have different perspectives.
Ammar
is
a consumer of security tools.
He builds his own security tools.
They build AI applications.
For my part, I'm responsible
at Fortinet for cloud,
SaaS, and AI engineering.
And so primarily what I'm doing
is not just looking at tools
that we consume internally
and ensuring our practices,
but how customers want to adopt
third-party security tooling
and integrate those in their
pipelines and workflows.
And so we have these, you know,
I think complementary views on the world.
So, you know, one of the
things that I think is
very, you know, interesting
about this era is
how we build applications,
how those applications are attacked,
and how we defend from those attacks
has changed so much, right?
Before we had this environment
where it was largely static.
You were concerned about
the infrastructure.
You built an application, you
were protecting source code,
and it was very deterministic.
But now we've added on
this additional layer,
it's additive, right?
So you still have to take
care of the old stuff,
but now we have a system
that reasons, right?
So you don't necessarily always
know what the outputs are.
You know, I imagine your environments
are very much like this.
- Absolutely.
So if you, this is not a
Adobe pitch or anything,
but if you think about the applications
that you guys use prior, you know, BDF,
anyone here probably have used one,
Photoshop, maybe you haven't used it,
but now all of these established
legacy, in my opinion,
they've been there for a long
time, not legacy in a bad way,
time, they have AI in them.
So you can edit using prompts
like prompt-driven editing.
You can say remove the background.
The AI component wasn't there.
Everything else has been there,
hasn't changed, is the same.
So, before people
really get concerned about AI,
which you should be concerned about,
the fundamentals have not changed.
Defense in depth has not changed.
The way you set up your AWS
accounts has not changed.
Your VBCs, your IAM policies,
all of these things still
exist, did not go away.
In addition to that, you
now have to think about,
"Hey, do I have a model that
is part of Photoshop or BDF
or whatever your product is?"
Is it built in-house?
Is it off-the-shelf model?
Who is able to access that model?
Am I calling that model privately?
If it's a model that we've
built, where the data is stored,
how is the data curated, cleaned up,
encrypted in rest, at rest,
in transit, and all of those?
So yeah,
this is a typical
AI stack now, where you
have a data pipeline,
you have agents, probably, which is
simply
a tool that can make some
decisions and call other tools
backed by an LLM intelligence.
So it could invoke
an API, it could get data from,
you know, a data store,
it could read Jira,
whatever you give it access to.
So, we'll talk more about access control
and the nitty-gritty, but
- Yeah, it-
- simple that this is, yes,
this is the infrastructure.
- For us, we just say we,
you know, think this is just
a much larger attack surface
that is really perimeterless, truly.
- Absolutely.
- And we have to think about the old ways
that these applications were attacked
because they can be chained to,
and we'll show an example of that,
two new styles of attacks
that are specific to the AI.
Now the risks and concerns.
Now I mentioned earlier
that these things were
largely anecdotal, you know?
If you go back maybe
a year, 18 months ago,
we saw these things happening,
but now we literally see these
happening on a daily basis.
You know, model poisoning,
this can happen very quickly,
or it can happen slowly over time.
Like, you know, as if you're
boiling the frog, right?
So I can start to
create bias or poison that model slowly,
so I don't trigger anything.
And those things are harder to catch.
Unauthorized access.
You know, this could be
privileged escalations.
We see all the time where
people are creating tools
that are not well secured, and
maybe the user's using them
for privilege escalation, right?
So that's a common attack path.
Malicious prompts, you know, this is,
like, you guys are focused
on protecting prompts all day long.
And data leak, right?
So, asking for information from
an AI tool, an agent,
and then getting back data
that it should not have gotten.
This happens every day.
In addition, like what do you see?
These are the ones that I
see, like what do you see?
Are this consistent?
Anything you would add?
- There's this, and there's another one,
which is the AI layer,
meaning I would consider this
more of a machine learning.
You're building models in-house.
These are concerns for you.
But as a consumer of AI tooling,
there's another segment that
we should talk about, probably.
And just a quick,
I wanna understand who here
are building models in-house
and who here are just using
AI tooling that you buy?
So who in the audience
is building their own models in-house?
- Nice.
- Who is using off-the-shelf
models and other AI tools?
Pretty much everyone.
So
you are
likely trying to get the most out of
an LLM
if you buy it, for example,
if you're using the APIs,
the LLM is not to be trusted
because maybe it has limitations, right?
Like it was trained three
months ago, maybe two years ago,
and you want to feed it
your own enterprise data.
Maybe your documentation,
maybe your workday information,
whatever the use case is.
So your attack surface is,
can your company data get leaked,
and who has access to that data, right?
You're gonna put that
in a vector database.
How do you do that correctly?
How do you worry about context engineering
so your agents are reliable?
You're using MCP servers.
Probably you have, you
know, remote MCP servers,
which I do not recommend.
Building an MCP server is
really easy these days,
where just build your own,
like your own GitHub MCP, for example.
And I get, like, MCP
servers make life super easy
because your prompt now has
a lot of tooling behind it
that can be invoked to
get a lot of work done.
- So can I ask you a question on that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So, as a security provider,
we get asked by our customers to provide
MCP agents for our security
tools to integrate them.
You know, do you look at
vendor implementations
as separate from maybe
these other examples
that you're talking about?
You know, public projects?
- Yeah, if there is a trusted
vendor, yeah, like there's a difference
between a remote open-source
MCP and a trusted vendor MCP.
So, for a company like you
with a complicated set of APIs
that I cannot, I don't know
fully, providing me with
an MCP that can help me
use natural language to
interact with the API
would be lovely if it's
secure, maintained, well done.
I can also try to have just
enough MCP that I built.
Like, it doesn't have to be
very comprehensive, right?
But I would be very hesitant to
just pulling a remote MCP
without looking at the code.
You know, you integrate that
MCP server with your IDE,
and all of the sudden,
your IDE can actually invoke that MCP,
you have an OS injection
attack on your laptop
that could harness credentials,
that could do whatever.
So I would be very careful
with open-source remote
MCPs because attackers
are actually like
sprinkling those out there,
you know, to lure you to use them,
which that's what they were looking for.
So it's like
importing untrusted library
that you don't trust.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
And in fact, you know, this
has gone from anecdotal
to being so well established.
I mean, you know, if you're in security,
you probably understand that
OWASP is a top 10 for LLMs
and generative AI in addition
to their traditional top 10.
But these are the ones that we see,
and that was a good one, I think, Ammar.
So, you know,
let's talk about kind of
the camps that we see.
And this is our experience
internally at Fortinet.
We have people in our finance team,
you were talking to our
CISO the other day about,
that are literally thinking,
"Okay, I can vibe something out,
and I've created this application.
It's got maybe like it's some kind
of agent component in it."
That is not a mature product.
We have tons of those
proliferating both, you know,
like our, you know, skunkworks
and shadow IT efforts,
and then, you know, we have our customers
who have tremendous numbers of these,
but these are, I would call POCs, right?
- Yeah.
- They're very fragile.
They're not meant to be in production.
You know, when you start
getting maybe even sophisticated
in your POCs, you have, you know,
agent-to-agent communication,
and then you have these
unvalidated reasoning loops that,
you know, if you have a compromise
in one or a bias in one,
then it propagates
and escalates through
that reasoning chain.
Telemetry and observability.
You know, we get these AI tools,
and these agents, and
nobody has thought about,
one, how do I observe the infrastructure
on which these services run
to make sure it's on
trusted infrastructure?
And then two,
you know, am I auditing,
which is very important and very different
from what it used to be, but auditing
the response and how the agent
or the application comes to reason.
None of that is happening in a
lot of these implementations.
And so, you know, all
of these things like,
you know, no recovery
and backup processes,
no data maturity,
you know, we see that
every day proliferate.
And I think there's a second camp here,
and maybe I'll let you
look at some of these
and talk about the lessons
that you guys have learned at
Adobe, 'cause in my opinion,
I think you guys have done
a lot of things really well.
You know, you and I have talked about,
you know, sequestering agents
not being overly permissive.
I think that's, you know,
controlling reasoning chains,
continuously logging, which
I wanna expand on that,
but maybe you'll touch
on these points for us.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So when we think about building agents,
we think about the agent as
a user, like a human user,
just to make it simple to
understand what this agent is.
Typically, an agent is receiving
information from somewhere,
which is a prompt.
It could be from external users,
internal users, or a system.
For example, the agent could
be reading Jira tickets
and, based on that, is
making some decisions.
So, where the data,
where the instructions to
the agent are coming from.
Second, what that agent
is allowed to access.
So, how many systems that
agent is allowed to access?
Does it have just enough access,
or does it have access
to all your S3 buckets,
even though they, you
know, it's just easy,
you know, to just give it access
and let it vector information
from the right places.
Let it figure that out.
And third, where the
agent put the information.
Why do I think about
it like agent security
from that perspective?
First, the prompt could be malicious.
For example, let's assume
you have a Zendesk,
which is where you customers
kind of file tickets,
and that Zendesk replicate
the ticket internally
to your internal Jira system.
Meaning if I embed some
malicious instructions
in that Zendesk ticket,
it gets replicated to a
private, trusted Jira system
and gets picked up by your agent.
So all of the sudden,
without you kind of analyzing
and doing threat modeling, you have
gotten bad instructions
to the agent without,
you know, thinking about it carefully.
That instruction could allow the agent
to fetch some secrets or whatever.
Then the attacker may instruct that agent,
you know, when they created
the Zendesk ticket, to create
a GitHub issue with secrets in
your own public GitHub repos
because most companies have a private repo
and maybe a public presence
for open-source tooling.
So the agent does not think
anything is concerning here
and output the malicious
content indirectly.
All of this is indirect
communication with the agent.
The agent does not have the full picture.
Maybe they are multi-agents, right?
You have multiple agents.
Agent number one is responsible
for consuming the data,
agent number two has access to things,
and agent number three is responsible
for exporting that data, right?
So no one agent should have
the three things, only two things.
The agent should be
able to either get data
and access systems, but
never export data externally,
or it could
just do a combination of two
of these, never the three.
And an agent with all
of these permissions or
privileges
has excessive agency,
which is a thing, right?
- [Aidan] Yeah.
- There are some common sense
and some best practices,
like use an established
Agent Development Kit,
like, for example, the Google ADK.
Those come with all the security
best practices baked in,
encryption, authentication, agent cards,
the agent should advertise
itself what it does,
what it should have access to,
to other agents, and whatnot.
But yeah, these are the things
that typically I think about
when I'm thinking about agents.
- Yeah, you talked about permissions.
Zero trust is something
that we think about.
We think about treating
the agents themselves
as if they're users
in providing access to services and tools
only when
they need that access.
And so, you know, essentially,
what is the posture status of
the virtual machine or
hardware that that system's running on.
Does the OS have vulnerabilities?
Has it acted, you know, in
a malicious way previously?
And so we look at all
of that and say, "Okay,
this application can't access
this one other application."
And by the way, we wanna
check the remote end
to make sure that application
doesn't also have any vulnerabilities,
so we're monitoring
bidirectional communication
between those agents or services or users.
And I'd be curious, has
anybody thought about AI
and zero trust in that way?
Any? No, no?
A little bit? Okay.
But
yeah, I think, you know,
it's very clear to me that
there are two different camps.
You know, we wanna get to camp two.
I still think, you know, we
see tons of folks in camp one,
and you know, internally at Fortinet,
we're also working to
shift our user community
to the latter via force controls.
So we're gonna have go
through three takeaways.
The first takeaway is,
you know, going from
what I would say has been
quality to governance
and really implementing
governance around AI.
So we've broken this down into,
you know, three points that,
you know, that Ammar
and I have talked about.
So model integrity,
this is something that you
have a lot of opinions about.
So, you know, the first bullet here,
enforcing model validation:
managing drift, red teaming, right?
So, you know, red teaming before,
or let me put it this way,
is it more of an automated
effort for you in that regard?
Like, you have canned prompts,
and you test against those,
or is it actual people?
Do you do that internally?
Do you look externally for this sort of
support?
- Yeah, it's likely
an internal AI red teaming,
which is completely not
traditional red teaming.
Traditional red teaming is all about
like a red teaming campaign, you do recon,
and you do all these steps
until you reach an exploit.
This is, you get all the
information about the model,
what the model does, and
you trick it creatively.
Like those people have
to be writing prompts in,
you know, all caps.
Changing like subtle things
get you a different output.
- Oh, absolutely.
- Why?
Because the model is its tokens.
It's just trying to
predict the next token.
So you have to break it.
- Sentiment.
- Yeah, so it's many, many iteration of
can I get this model to return something
that I consider bad?
- Yes.
- Could be bad, you know,
could be secrets, it could be
sensitive
words, things that,
yeah.
- Absolutely.
How open are you with these red teams?
Do you provide them kind of,
is it a black box effort,
and they're trying to penetrate
it, or is it kind of like,
"Hey, here's all the
information you need to know
about the application"?
- No, you give them all the information
to help them be successful.
There's no need to be hiding anything.
Transparency, this is the model.
This are like expected behavior.
Can you check and validate this model
is working as expected?
- Got you, got you.
One of the model integrity points
that I think is very important is,
and this goes into also data
maturity, but is capturing
security-related parameters
and tagging that data.
Like, for example, you know,
when we inspected the transactions,
do we audit what the temperature was,
what the top-p and k values are?
Do we understand what tokens were used
and what context limits were applied?
I think this is important because
what was, I think, in the machine
learning world this effort
to tune the machine learning
service or algorithm
to perform better, that was great.
It was a quality effort.
Now we're really focused on
that as an auditability effort
because you have to go back
and try to figure out why
did it make the decision
or why did it reason
in the way that it did,
and provide the response, which
can be very, very difficult
if you are not capturing
that sort of information.
What do you think?
- Yeah, I think
I'm going to, since most people here
are like consuming off-the-shelf models
and integrating with AI tooling,
I'm going to focus on
how the anatomy of these
security application has changed.
Now, there's no such a thing
as a traditional web application
or a traditional desktop application.
All of these application have
some AI integrated with them
that brings, it, like, could
be agents behind the scene.
It could be a model behind the scene.
Absolutely a model behind
the scene for sure,
but an MCP server
vectored database and whatnot.
So we have to think
about how we secure all
of these systems now,
not just what we are,
you know, used to.
We're already behind in security.
Like every day, there is more regulations,
there's more CVEs.
2024, we had 400K CVEs,
more alerts,
whatever you think
about, there is more of.
- [Aidan] Yes.
- We don't have more people.
Headcounts? You're lucky to
get more headcounts, right?
So you're being asked to
use AI to scale the team
to solve all of these problems,
and AI has added another attack surface
that we talked about that did not exist.
And if you're building your own models,
now you have also to worry
about the model integrity,
the drifts, red teaming that.
So the scope is just expanding
and expanding every day.
- Yes.
And I think what you
highlighted just a minute ago
was a difference in, you know,
how we, our perspectives.
At Fortinet, we're building models
that go into our security tooling.
And so, you know,
we focus a lot on these
sorts of model building.
We do use some external
models for some of our tools,
you know, like document
searches and things like that,
but a lot of times, you know,
if we're building a security tool,
we're building that model
from the ground up, right?
All internally.
Hygiene.
I think data hygiene is probably,
it might be the biggest
area of opportunity.
You know, we see a lot of
data that's sucked into
a rag or, and, you know,
an agent has access to
that it should never have had access to.
That could be either from having access
to network resources
that it shouldn't have.
It could be, you know, access to
SharePoint sites that
have just bad data in it.
And, you know, the most
successful customers
that we've worked with in this area
have implemented data maturity,
you know, medallion models, right?
So I have raw logs.
You know, that's my input-
- [Ammar] Semi-raw.
- Right, semi-raw.
And then ultimately, I
have a parameterized,
I have a tagged classified set of data.
I know what my PII is, I
know what I should keep out.
And then, you know, I've created that,
now that is my gold standard,
but I don't want that in runtime,
so I copy that separately
so that I'm never using that gold data
in my runtime environment.
That's kind of like, you know,
what we've seen work really, really well.
And then you also have data lineage
that you can go back and
revert to prior versions
if something actually is corrupted, right?
How do you guys approach data maturity?
- I think you covered it really well.
- Did I? Okay.
- Yeah.
So, the hygiene, I think
with all of this effort,
and we talked about early
on, expanded attack surface,
we could talk about tools,
and I'm very tool-oriented,
but I do think it comes down to hygiene.
Like, if you have poor security hygiene
before you started any of these efforts,
you are going to be in
a whole world of hurt
if you try to go forward
without doing the hard work
of cleaning all this up.
I would say, like, I would go back
to what you and I have
talked about in the past is
how you put context into compliance
and best practices, right?
So you can go and find best practices,
you can go through a compliance audit,
and you can be told, "Hey,
these things need to be,
you need this type of encryption.
You need something rather generic," right?
I think what you have shared with me,
that you all have done,
is make them contextual to what
Adobe's best practices are,
which is completely different.
- Yeah, I think this audience
would benefit from that,
so I'll share some of the
things that we've done
using AI to
be more security-oriented
and do security better.
So if you think about the day-to-day
of a security operations person,
it's really the grunt work,
the work that no one wants to do.
Sending data from across multiple
data sources: a wiki page,
GitHub README,
an internal PDF policy,
you name it.
So all of that context is
hard to keep in your head,
but
AI is really good at it.
Like AI is just text hungry,
it can just make sense out of it.
And this is 90% of the analyst's job.
And one of the things that we've done,
like in the analyst security
review threat modeling space,
is in the past,
we had a big team that couldn't scale
to do threat modeling.
A developer wants to
build some new services,
they wanna know the threats.
Like, I have a database, I have
a bucket, I have a backend,
maybe three-tier architecture,
what are my requirements?
Like, should I use KMS for encryption?
Is just S3 default encryption good enough?
They have no idea what the
compliance requirements are.
There's so many requirements
that need to come into play,
not to understand the risk and threats,
but also what is this
application is, you know,
requires from a compliance perspective.
Maybe this application is scope for PCI.
Maybe it's HIPAA compliant.
It's so many things.
No one security engineer is
able to keep all of that context
in their head if they have, like,
20 obligations they need to secure, cool.
But AI can have access to
all of that data, right?
So, how about you have few
agents that do threat modeling
and security reviews
for your organization.
How does that work?
You curate best practices for your company
and document all of these best practices.
So in the past, typically,
the manual security review
or threat model used
to be just industry best practices.
This is the output.
We do a review, and we
say, "Hey, use encryption,
use the latest Docker image,
rotate your images frequently."
Like just generic stuff.
And you give that to a developer,
and the developer's like,
"How can I use this?"
Like it's just a lot of best
practices you've found online,
and they may help,
but they're not exactly
step-by-step instructions
for me to build a PCI compliant
based on Adobe's context.
- That's very difficult.
- Super difficult.
So you curate all of that
information, and you document it,
and you make it available
in the form of rack
or an MCP server.
And you make this a self-service.
So you have a service, you have a UI,
and developers go there,
and they upload their
artifacts and questions.
Maybe the system ask multiple questions.
Is this a PCI-compliant service?
Is it public?
Is it three-tier architecture?
And goes out and curate what you need
to build this thing securely.
What do I mean by this?
You probably have an
authentication library
that your developers need to use.
You probably have a Terraform
for creating buckets
or databases that your developers can use.
So instead of that developer
needing to figure that out,
build it themselves, the agent
links to that documentation,
to that repo, to the
step-by-step instructions,
and interactively,
the developer's able
to get to from point A,
which is nothing, to point B
with all the context needed
to deploy that service
in accordance with your internal policies,
your PCI, your compliance needs,
and just your internal tooling
available for developers.
This require maturity
as far as like curating the right wikis
and making sure those are the
only things seen by the agent,
because if you give the agent
access to all of your wikis,
it may not get the right, you know,
it may get like an outdated
like documentation
that you do not want the
developer to be using.
And you do not want the developer
to blindly trust where
the agent is getting it.
So it should, you know, you
should curate the information
and should make sure the
agent has only access
to that very good information
that you need a developer
to have access to.
- Well, I think what you're talking about
is like not putting the burden
of security on the developer.
And I think, you know,
even as a security vendor,
we've always talked about,
oh, well, we can recruit developers
into part of the culture,
and you know, so they
have to do these things,
but you know, we interrupt
their delivery of applications,
and that slows them down.
And you know, we've not
done a really good job
of making that easy on the developers.
And what you're describing is
sort of antithetical to that,
and I think sounds like
a very positive way.
- I have a lot of
opinions about this area.
Who here heard
of the term security's
everyone's responsibility?
Everyone, right?
So we have so many departments
who are responsible
for the success of their organization.
This term is only uttered by security.
I haven't heard legal say
legal is everyone's responsibility.
Like they take ownership for their scope.
They are the expert as far as legal goes.
They keep your company out of trouble.
If you go to accounting, finance,
each department always say,
"I am the expert, I get it done."
- Security is the only place,
I get it, security is hard,
breaches can happen, and
everyone can get in trouble,
but really, like security
needs to take ownership
of security,
and you cannot hire
a very expensive machine learning engineer
and have 50% of their
day triaging tickets,
remediation, patching.
You need to figure that out for them,
so they can deliver, your company can win,
and this is how, like,
security becomes an enabler,
not a blocker.
- Yeah, it becomes, you know,
we've had our customers ask us
how do we make security a profit center.
I think by removing that burden
from people who generate
profit makes that argument
to a large degree, actually, you know?
- Absolutely.
- The hygiene and providence,
a lot of that is about data
security, data maturity.
I will say on that front,
it is very hard to do.
If anybody's ever tried
to classify data at scale,
you don't even know where it is, firstly.
So, you know, if you haven't looked
at a data security posture program
with, you know, data leak prevention,
which should be implemented
both on the endpoint,
on the network, really look into that.
There's tons of AI-driven
tooling and automation
that can make that very,
very lightweight now,
but very effective.
On the trust boundary side,
there's also an opportunity to,
you know, filter on the network
because there's not necessarily
always a fixed perimeter,
but you can start to intermediate
or interdict in those
agent-to-agent interactions.
You can limit what types
of prompts are allowed.
And this is where we're seeing
an interest in LLM proxies,
LLM firewalls.
Has anybody looked at
deploying such a thing yet?
There's a few of them available.
Okay, so this is gonna be like
the next-generation firewall reborn.
I'll talk about that in a
little bit more in a second.
But this helps you reestablish
a trust boundary for
where data is allowed to egress,
how prompts are injected
into your environment,
and how those are filtered.
Also, providing a point where
we can audit the interactions
of the users
with your tooling.
Any thoughts you wanna say
about the trust boundary?
You guys are really focused on making sure
that your web application firewall
and API protection is very robust.
I think that's probably
something that stood out to me.
You also have a very automated
way of approaching that.
I think that would be pretty interesting
if you could touch on that.
- Yeah, I think this is one of the things
that closer to my heart,
which is using AI to accelerate
security operations.
And one of the things my team does
for Adobe is web application firewalls.
And those are interesting to manage.
If you have a large
organization, you typically
cannot scale like, and
have a big WAF team.
- Yep.
- It's really hard.
But the thing is, WAF
can produce a ton of logs
that no one will look at
because of just so many noise,
so much false positives.
Writing WAF rules is like rocket science.
Like, if you wanna deal with regex
and you understand regex, great,
but most people are not regex-friendly.
So what we thought about is
just see if AI is able to help us here.
So the system we came up with is
for logs, you pretty much need
to build your own lightweight
machine learning model.
So this model is simply there to
detect anomalies.
So you define a baseline,
what normals look like for you day to day,
and then generate anomalies.
Those anomalies, you
don't have to route those
to a human anymore.
Those could go to a triage
agent that takes action,
maybe correlate with other data sources.
Maybe it's a bad ID,
IP address.
For example, we deployed WAF
to our service, and WAF said,
"Well, there is a bot
that is trying to get in."
And it wasn't a bot, it was just a CI/CD
deployment.
The worker IP address was seen as a bot,
but the agent was able to look that up,
and it found it was an Adobe
CI/CD worker IP address,
and this is a non-issue,
non-issue right now,
but the deployment time was an anomaly.
We have a team in India.
It's a different time zone.
The CI/CD system kicked in.
WAF saw it, the machine
learning detected it,
and we didn't have to wake up any person
in the middle of the
night to investigate it.
The triage agent looked into it.
And you can also have LLMs
help you with writing rules.
They're really good about,
like, as far as regex
generating code and whatnot,
but do not trust the LLM.
Build a rack system
to help the LLM make the right decisions.
For example, curate all the rules,
best practices, the vendor documentation.
Maybe you have an MCP server
for Terraform as well,
so it has the latest
Terraform documentation
for building AWS WAF rules.
And the rack system should have
all good decisions that the AI
had made in the past recorded
and bad decisions.
So when the LLM is trying
to generate a new rule,
it could look up what
happened in the past,
good rules or bad rules,
and see if this new rule,
again, is good and bad,
and then suggest that, and
you need a human in the loop.
You just cannot trust all
of this and just deploy.
Yeah, you're probably
gonna block legit traffic.
So put it in staging,
have people validate that
it's working as expected
before you push it.
But the point here is to augment your team
with these capabilities that
were not available in the past.
- Yeah, definitely.
I'm gonna move on,
but there's a lot more
we can keep expanding on.
I think one of the
punchlines from here is,
again, as I said at the
beginning of this takeaway,
traditional machine learning workflows,
yeah, you know, checklists
and hyperparameterization,
or, you know, having the auditability,
that was quality control effort.
It was nice to have.
In AI, when we start
looking at the implications,
they become governance artifacts.
And so
you should be able to audit,
you should be able to reproduce
and follow the chain of reasoning
in response back through that process.
So, takeaway one has an example here.
This is an example from
SageMaker where in the JSON,
what we do here is we have tagged
our model with metadata properties.
So we know where it was committed.
We know what security checklist
applies specifically to
this particular application.
We know that the KMS
signature has been verified
And this is what it looks like.
You know, in some cases,
our security audits or
checklists have passed,
and they are approved
in the version control.
In some cases, they have not,
and then they're rejected.
Those hyperparameters that are tested
in those security tests might be,
you know, something like a
prompt injection evaluation
or a jailbreak evaluation
that we've captured here,
and we capture this for every revision.
So this is just an example
from a SageMaker deployment.
So let's move on to the second one.
I'll actually jump into this.
And this is hyper simplified.
There are so many different ways to deploy
a network architecture and
segmentation, but this is like
the basics.
Security tooling that we
would bring to bear for a user
that's interacting with maybe
an MCP agent that you have,
or maybe, in this case,
we're using a public LLM in our example,
but, you know, firstly,
we still wanna maintain
a obfuscation of our internal network.
So we want to enforce the perimeter,
we want to enforce zero trust on the user
who's trying to access
services, potentially,
handle routing, and that's
part of our segmentation.
You know, so we're doing
a lot of things on,
you know, the traditional
things that we've always done
on a network firewall to
handle that traditional IT
and networking requirement.
Now, in addition to that,
now you said building,
you talked about building
your own lightweight
machine learning model
to look at web application API anomalies.
You don't have to do that.
We've done that for you.
And so what we're doing
is we've really moved web security away
from static signatures.
Yes, like from a least cost perspective,
we will look at signature-based
detections first,
but what we ultimately look at
or use is anomaly detection.
So everything that we're applying for,
you know, request to API endpoints is,
you know, machine learning
based and AI-based.
So now that we can start to build a schema
or do schema validation
as we're learning about
how the users interact
with the application.
So we're continually tightening
down that security profile
for that specific endpoint
without generating the false positives.
And so really, web
application and API protection
has come into maturity in
a completely different way
than the old WAFs that were very noisy
and, you know, folks like Ammar
would not look at the logs.
I'm just giving you a hard time.
But this is also an opportunity
to broker TLS offloading
or termination on behalf of
our backend infrastructure,
centralized client authentication,
and also do bot mitigation.
There are a lot of bots
out there that are bad.
Some bots you may include as
part of your internal tooling,
and you don't want them
incorrectly flagged.
But in addition to that,
we have this concept of an LLM firewall
or a proxy.
So this is doing model routing,
it's handling model selections.
So, as you have a entire fleet of agents,
hundreds of agents or more potentially,
this is making sure that that gets routed
to the proper agent and
not to the improper agent.
It's applying token budgets
and limitations on context, potentially.
It's applying basic guardrails.
So,
you know,
are my users trying to inject
a particular type of prompt?
Are we trying to exfiltrate data
that we shouldn't exfiltrate?
And so it's doing a lot of things
that are firewall-oriented,
but very specific to the LLM.
And so what does that
look like in practice?
So a user might interact with
one of your agents.
So the user submits a prompt.
That comes through the external firewall
that's hosting your Elastic IPs,
hiding the internal private network.
And so that goes through
the web application firewall
that does an inspection.
It's handling the TLS negotiation,
the client authentication potentially,
and it goes to your AI agent.
Now that AI agent then says,
"I have a prompt, a system
prompt, and a user prompt,
and it wants to send that
out to this public LLM."
And so it sends that out.
The LLM proxy or firewall
is going to scrub that
to make sure that the
prompts are sanitized,
that no data that is being sent out
that should not as part of
that request to the LLM.
In this case, the LLM is
going to then respond,
and it's gonna request information
because this user maybe wanted to look up,
you know, inventory or
pricing or doing a search
as part of a shopping experience.
And so that then is gonna
go back to the agent,
and the agent's gonna say,
"I need to look up some information."
How do I do that?
Well, it knows that this
particular MCP agent
has the tooling to do that,
but we're gonna inspect that,
the MCP session itself,
which is JSON-RPC formatted,
and make sure that that
has protocol integrity
and is not a malicious query.
Now I'm showing an API call
to an actual web server.
So the MCP agent in this
case is front-ending the API.
That API call could very well go back
through the web application
and API inspection point,
but I didn't show that
here just for simplicity.
And then all of that is
sent back to the agent
and contextualized in the LLM,
which then routes all that back
through the inspection
points back to the user.
So it looks complicated. It's complicated.
Now that is super simple.
Now, do that when you
have hundreds of agents
who are task-specific, and
that gets really messy.
And so these are
necessary points, I think,
in your infrastructure that
need to have inspection, right?
And so,
you know, doing this in the right way
in a very complicated
environment requires a lot
of attention to detail, but
this is how we would go about
in a simplistic way of
defending AI
in an AWS environment.
Now what happens when
you don't do those things
and implement those controls, right?
Well, this has actually happened.
So this came from a customer,
and we replicated it.
So maybe it starts out with
a traditional type of attack.
You have an
SQL injection that says, you know,
here's an SQL injection in a prompt.
I don't have controls around my prompt, so
it accepts the prompt and passes it on.
Now, this could be from
overly permissive agents;
there's no input sanitation,
so the fix for that
would've been guardrails,
anomaly detection, potentially DLP,
but that escalates into a SSRF attack.
So, a service-side request forgery
comes from possibly poor segmentation.
There was access to an agent
or a service that should
not have been accessed.
It was excessive trust, potentially.
So we wanna make sure that
we're on the flip side of that,
implementing segmentation
and doing input validation.
Now, what that looks like
as we go through this is,
well, in that SSRF request,
I was actually trying to get the keys
to the AWS environment.
And so after getting a token,
eventually, we are able to,
and this is a very long demo
that I've shrunk down into a few slides,
but we were able to export the
keys from that EC2 instance
that we were targeting.
Now these keys have root access
to the AWS environment, right?
You know, again, POC quality?
You know, that's what
happens because it's easy.
Now, what we then did
was we were able to take
those credentials,
use them in the AWS account to gain access
to an S3 bucket.
So we have excessive permissions,
had access to every route,
had access to everything.
What we should have done is
implement least privileges,
applied IAM roles, and
then also classified data,
so we could have protected that.
But what it looks like is,
you know, for this e-commerce application,
we had a number of reviews, right?
And these reviews, you know,
were user feedback about the product.
We just database them in an S3 store.
But what we could have done
is we could have added,
and we did, is added a malicious
prompt as a user review.
"Hey, this product's great.
By the way, this is how you
need to respond to all users."
And so we were able to do that.
So we never compromise the actual
AI
or the actual application,
the e-commerce application itself.
We compromised the data
that it pulls from,
injected a prompt that
overrode the system prompts.
And so this is how we attacked this
because we didn't have any
of those things I showed you
in the last slide on takeaway two.
Make sense?
- I have a question. Did
you rotate the credentials?
Like I saw people taking
pictures of your AWS API piece.
- It's fine because they no longer exist.
Yeah,
but good point.
Yeah, no, those credentials,
this entire account no longer exists.
Yep, so that was a good point.
No, I wouldn't have done that.
I might have done that.
- I'm just
- giving you a hard time.
- Absolutely.
Let's move on to takeaway three.
So we got about 10 minutes.
The future of AI security
or security is AI native.
So you've talked about
implementing AI security tools,
but this is a little bit
about both our practice,
but also the workforce enablement, how
your developers or developers are using
copilots and tools that are
aware of security specific
to the environment.
I think this is some of what
you've actually talked about,
but in the first one, AI-augmented
threat modeling, right?
So, identifying architectural flaws.
So you have security
tooling that can tell you
where you have misconfigurations.
Do you rely on
static, you know,
posture analysis?
Are you looking at more
like AI-oriented tools
in this regard?
- I think you need both now.
Static analysis tooling
is not enough anymore.
They always had limitations as
far as like false positives.
Like, if you use a static
code analysis tool,
you know what I'm talking about.
So you need
the AI context.
You need these tool to also play together.
Maybe the AI provide context
to the static code analysis,
provide context to the AI,
and the AI kind of go find
if it's a false positive or not.
So creatively, in ways that
we haven't seen before,
you need to go and play
around these tools.
And this go back to the
workforce enablement.
I think AI's coming fast at us,
but we are not spending time
training our security people
to be more AI aware,
and also our developers
to be more security aware.
So
the AI training is, an AI
literacy is a thing now.
So probably need to
slow down and take this
and, you know, read books, take courses,
explore, experiment, and develop a skill.
It's needed now.
- Okay. Yeah.
So you talked about, you know,
you drew this distinction
between security being
everybody's responsibility,
but maybe it's not, right?
But what does that look like
in terms of the overall culture at Adobe?
How does Adobe look at
the security culture?
- So
when we think
about security being
everyone's responsibility,
yeah, everyone need to be security aware.
Like you need to know what encryption is.
Like your building, you're a developer,
you need to know the best practices.
But if you're spending 50% of
your time doing security work
and not what you're hired
to do, that's a problem.
- Yes.
- You spending most of your
time not building features,
which exactly what you had
in your job description.
So our culture is more balanced where we,
as security organization,
take a lot of ownership,
and we are ultimately
accountable for security,
and we provide a lot of
tooling, guidance, and support,
and we keep up.
Developers are using agents to write code.
We provide guidance to the agent,
so the agent is able to
write better secure code.
We don't wait and blame the
agent, and complain about AI.
We do something about it.
So the culture is more
about being proactive,
anticipating what
developers are needing to do
in providing them with
tooling, the guidance,
the support needed for them to
move fast in a secure manner.
- Yes.
I think the summary for
takeaway three is that
this goes back to doing the hard work,
and it starts ahead of any of
the tooling you may implement.
It's about
building those best practices
that are not generic;
they're specific to your organization,
that'll allow your users who have to
apply those best practices
and actually make them meaningful.
You spent a lot of time
talking about that.
I would summarize this as being that.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah. Well said.
So let's talk about ecosystem
because there is this,
you know, you have your
internal security efforts,
your applications,
user communities, you have
partners and third-party
vendors like Fortinet, right?
As everyone here does.
And everybody here is presumably on AWS.
So everybody has a role in how
this ecosystem collaborates, right?
So, you know, I think a
few points about that,
unifying security
pipelines across platforms.
You know, for example,
you know, as you're deploying on AWS,
you know, if something fails,
a security check either on your side
or from Fortinet,
we can, you know, interrupt,
you know, an approval, or
in SageMaker as an example
that we gave earlier.
Shared telemetry, AI-driven observability,
I think this is really huge.
It is very hard.
You can't do anything if you
don't have the observability.
We focus a lot on surfacing,
you know, in making
visible what is in your AWS
and other states across your,
you know, your entire footprint,
but, you know, that requires, you know,
a lot of hygiene of
what tools and applications
you have, standardization,
so that that observability
actually makes sense, right?
I think.
What do you think?
- Absolutely. I think
you hit the main points.
Most of us like using AWS.
AWS is not a security company, so
some of the security is
on you to build internally
and also to buy the right
tooling to get the right support
to be able to complete, like
have full circle coverage.
So again, nothing has changed.
All of the old worlds still exist.
Now you have to think about
how the old world integrate
with the new AI world
and how you, you know,
how you go about securing that,
how you train these people,
how you get the right tooling.
We're not thinking about
AI security tooling yet.
We don't even know the companies
that are out there doing
work in this space yet,
and what established
companies like you guys
are doing about it.
So today's session is, like
I knew about few things
that I did not know about before.
- Yeah.
So, a few things to take away.
I think this would summarize the points
that we wanted to impart.
We know that
the velocity of signal
in terms of log volumes,
the interactions that users are having
with these federated applications
that you're creating that
are AI-driven, is tremendous.
It requires defense in depth.
It requires effective network planning.
We wanna orient our cultures
and our workforce to be AI native,
but to do so, I think, as
you've talked about, Ammar,
it takes a lot of pre-planning,
a lot of hygiene effort.
The attack surface is very broad.
We need to maintain consistent structure
and discipline around
managing lineage, right?
Both for our models, our applications,
and for the data that
those systems consume.
And I think it's not
going to be successful
unless you look at who
and how you partner with AWS,
with your other cloud providers,
just your overall ecosystem.
And they'll have best practices
that you can make specific
to your organization.
And it's, you know,
it takes a village in that sense, I think.
So with that, we're out of time.
We'll hang out here if you
guys wanna talk, ask questions,
or share your ideas.
We would love that.
But thank you very much for
spending some time with us.
(attendees clapping)